Let's go next to our caller from the four
Oh four area code who's calling today from
four zero four.
Hi, this is Simon from the Davenport, Iowa
area.
Hey, Simon, and what's going on today?
Hi.
So a big fan of the show.
I've been watching for two years now.
Thank you.
Um, so you may find this interesting.
Um, so Tulsi Gabard has some signs up in the,
uh, area.
And, uh, you know, I see like she would, she's
doing the most she can with like the money
that she has left.
You know what I mean?
Like I feel like she's, she's like doing like
a last push, like they're placed in like a
certain way where it's like you might think
that, you know, they're just placed in that,
you know what I mean?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
So Telsey has signs and the signs are good
or the signs are not good or what, what are
the signs are desperate sign of different
desperation.
They do.
Yeah.
That's what I'm trying to say.
That they seem like they're signs of desperation.
And, um, so that's the first thing.
Second thing is that was a little weird.
The second thing is, uh, yeah.
Okay.
So I've been, uh, looking at your, um, commentaries
on, um, uh, Bernie's chances of passing Medicare
for all.
Okay.
Um, and I see like you're missing a factor
and that factor being, um, that in the event
we have a president Sanders, he is, um, saying
that he's going to rally the people together.
Um, towards the goal of Medicare for all it
maybe get out in the streets.
And I feel like that's really what's going
to be the, the, the thing that tips it over
the edge in the end.
So what are your thoughts on that?
I feel like you're missing a factor.
I'm not missing it.
Um, I am just aware of the reality that in
the United States, um, there is a long history
of throwing just enough of a bone to the people
to prevent the serious type of protest, mass
rallies in urban centers, strategic, um, absences
from work in order to cripple industry.
There's a history in the United States of
the establishment and the corporate powers
that be doing just enough to prevent that
from happening and keeping people, keeping
workers in a precarious enough state so that
they lack the wherewithal and resources to
do that because they make the calculus of,
well, they threw me a bone and I can't really
afford to do that.
So instead I'm just going to go to work.
I completely appreciate the idea of Bernie
Sanders.
If elected saying, listen everybody, this
is an emergency.
We need to pass Medicare for all right now.
I think that it is just a miscalculation to
imagine that Bernie doing that is actually
going to generate, uh, the type of activism
that will Medicare for all past given the
degree to which the corporate powers that
be and the Republican party and insurance
companies will activate against it.
I'm not dismissing the power of activism.
I'm not a do I, I just am, uh, less idealistic
than some others and people can disagree with
me and that's totally fine.
Um, but I just don't see that as likely.
I would love to be proven wrong, you know,
to be clear, I'm not saying I would be against
that.
I think it would be great to actually see
a president say, Hey, everybody, we've got
to do this thing.
The thing is called Medicare for all, and
here's what you need to do.
That would be lovely.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
My prediction may be wrong and I would love
to be wrong.
I, it's not that I'm missing it, I just don't
have the same interpretation as you of you
as you do.
Have the likelihood that that will, we'll
get it.
Get it done.
Okay.
David, thank you very much.
Um, yeah, have a good day.
All right.
You too.
Thank you so much.